kristen really opened up here revealing
to me that her
surprise breakup was actually years in
the making
when you're married and you have kids
you work really damn hard at it and we
worked hard at it and it just didn't
work i met jay when i was 23. you know i
was a kid
but we tried we tried everything but at
the end of the day
we weren't happy how did you get to the
decision
to say i am closing this chapter it was
not an easy decision
obviously and it was something that i
truly thought about
every single day for over two years and
it was the hardest decision that i have
ever made
kristin split from husband jay cutler
after three kids and 10 years together
came as a shocked most she cited marital
misconduct as the reason for the divorce
and it all played out behind the scenes
of the couple's three-season reality
show
very capillary meeting you halfway right
there in the middle
we did a good job of kind of keeping
that private
as much as possible you know i think we
gave a couple glimpses into it but
nothing to what was really going on um
and yeah the decision to end the show
was that i didn't want to talk about
my divorce on camera and have to expose
that you know i really i think that some
things
should be kept private it's just been
challenging and finding time for us
to be honest i kind of got what i needed
from the show i did it solely for
uncommon james
that was the only reason why i did it
well it paid off kristin's worth a
reported 30 million dollars in part
thanks to uncommon james and her
cookbooks her latest
true comfort is out tomorrow the
cookbook is gluten-free it has limited
dairy
nothing white so no white sugar no white
salt no white flour that's how i eat on
a daily basis
i sat down with kristen at the catalina
casino on catalina island
where she was doing a photo shoot for
her line's new spring collection
tell me a little bit about why
butterflies were important for this
collection
butterflies have always been a really
comforting nice sign for me when i'm
going through tough times
i actually just got a little butterfly
tattoo i haven't told my dad yet
he's probably not going to be thrilled
about it but you know i'm almost 34. i
can make my own decisions
yeah we first saw that rebel spirit 16
years ago today when laguna beach first
premiered i'm the only one
the hit reality show skyrocketed her to
stardom
this is you doing a little hosting
uh-oh for entertainment tonight oh i
don't want to watch this i'm like
already
disgusted boom that's about it so if
you're ever down in laguna beach give me
a call
those extensions i'm glad those days are
behind me
now but we will see you on the hills
right you filmed a little something i
think i have to do an episode
that wasn't heidi and adriana came on
very cavalry so the trade-off was
episode for episodes so maybe i'll go
and stir some things up you know
and then leave one episode stir the pot
and i'm out
you